the United States has called for an
immediate halt to a military offensive
by rebel Libyan general Khalifa Haftar
to seize the capital Tripoli troops
loyal to ha ha are reported to be
advancing on the city after launching
the operation on Thursday at least 30
people have been killed and dozens
injured in the fighting forces aligned
to the un-backed government in Tripoli
say they have started a
counter-offensive to defend the city
well for more on this let's bring in
Chris Steven he is the guardians Libya
correspondent Chris what are you hearing
about the situation on the ground in
Libya
yeah well the fighting continues I mean
overnight we've have task forces have
been making some gains they're pushing
in from the southern suburbs but they're
meeting a lot of resistance from
militias in the city so yes it's that
the fifth day and casualties are
mounting how likely is it Chris that
general half tower will actually succeed
with his offensive and his march on the
capital I think it's hard to know I mean
he has very powerful forces excuse me
he's already captured the east of Libya
and the south of Libya so if it in
Tripoli is that is the final sort of
stop but on the other hand this is a big
city there's a lot of forces there
opposing him so it's a trial of strength
really okay a trial of strength for the
man who seems determined to seize power
what would happen do you think if
general ha ha did manage to take power
in Libya well he said that he he favors
democracy but he has a very very strong
rule so he wanted to be a very ordered
democracy when he's pitched the Libyan
people is I can get rid of all these
militias and all this chaos and install
a regular army and police forces but of
course Libyans will think well does that
make it mean that we come back to being
a dictatorship
now the whole world is watching what's
happening in Libya seeing it's still
falling apart is there anything that the
international community can do the
United Nations for example to help solve
this conflict
well the options are very limited the
the EU foreign ministers are meeting
today in Brussels and people will be
looking to them to see what they can
come up with but military interventions
not on the cards sanctions could be it
could be perhaps organized but there's a
big split in the international community
countries including France Russia Egypt
are supporting F times so the
internationals really the first step is
to see they can get a consensus now the
European Union has been working with
Libya to try to keep refugees from from
leaving the country and taking to the
water on that perilous journey to Europe
where what happens to the refugees in
the middle of this conflict
yeah the UN is very concerned you have
thousands of migrants in detention
centers already in very grim conditions
in the middle of Tripoli and they've
sort of lost contact with them so
there's a great deal of concern what
happens to them Chris thank you very
much for bringing us up-to-date that was
Chris Stephen there with the British
Daily The Guardian